[Musique]
dans son laboratoire en Illinois de
geochimiste Claire Paterson découvre
enfin ce qu'il cherche depuis 5 ans la
Terre a été formée il y a 4,55 milliards
d'années
pour la première fois on obtient une
datation précise de l'âge de la Terre et
de notre système solaire
c'était en 1953 il y a 70 ans
[Musique]
pour réussir cette exploit il fallait
d'abord trouver une roche aussi vieille
que notre planète elle-même mais comment
y arriver
en cherchant dans les crackers d'impact
pour des météorites
ces roches de l'espace sont des résidus
des vestiges de la formation du système
solaire ils ont donc été formés au tout
début du système solaire en même temps
que la terre
en obtenant la datation d'une météorite
on trouverait alors l'âge de notre
planète
l'échantillon étudié par Claire
Patterson et la météorite de canyon
Diablo un cratère d'impact en Arizona
ces cristaux contiennent naturellement
de l’uranium un élément radioactif qui
se désintègre peu à peu en plan et on
connaît sa vitesse de désintégration
ainsi en mesurant avec une extrême
précision les proportions de plomb et
d'uranium contenu dans ces cristaux on
peut trouver l'âge de la météorite la
réponse
4,55 milliards d'années
c'était la datation la plus ancienne
jamais obtenue
depuis de nouvelles méthodes ont permis
de confirmer la découverte de Battle Sun
et aujourd'hui encore 70 ans plus tard
c'est toujours ce chiffre que les
scientifiques retiennent comme étant
l'âge de la Terre et du système solaire